he broke his neck
don't apologize which way you go no no
this is definitely another way I'll come
this way come with me
yeah as soon as she stood up I'm like
okay
and then you tripped her good move yeah
I saw you just go like that real quick
yep
dude you can come sit down dude you
don't have to wait is that the guy you
were sitting next to does he know what I
said do you not want to sit in the front
you can stay back there oh
you don't have to apologize
do you mind if I ask why
are you farting
are you farting and just being polite is
that what's happening are you guys
arguing right now and so yeah
did you this up for everybody
it is the most bizarre thing I want you
to know everybody in here wants to know
what the is going on
broke his neck and it fell off
don't apologize which way you go no no
this is definitely another way I'll come
this way come with me
now that they're gone I want to hear
ideas about why he never came back to
this table what's your theory
or pre-game but why didn't he come back
do you think he was
got it
there's no way that was the first step
no way
first date no
because first day even just left
first he's not beholding the stick
around for that yeah no so okay I like
the down the ramp
Theory
I think he was like going up the ramp
was tough going down it's gonna be
impossible
oh he was trying to get her to leave
yeah and so she went that way
she went that way yeah she was trying to
dig her way out yeah yeah
with her face
yeah definitely not first date
they were married
yeah they both had wedding rings though
what was that yeah dude there's no way
on a first date he sticks around if he's
embarrassed on a first date I just don't
give a I'm just leaving I might
leave cap what's that
yeah yeah
right there
he was with endearing distance of what
was going on yeah yeah yeah and this and
he you saw how quickly he ran up to help
her off the ground
that was a real tough relationship to
read I'll tell you what
hey
[Music]
[Applause]